the pace of technological change could
at times seem bewildering
quite a good way of working out what is
going to be coming next is to ask the
people who control the tech budgets at
companies so that's what bloomberg
business week teamed up with bloomberg
intelligence the analysis arm of
bloomberg lp to do they asked about 3
000 technology leaders across a range of
industries how they would be spending
their money in the years to come and the
findings were interesting now almost
half of them are going to increase their
technology budgets by nine percent or
more perhaps that in and of itself not
that surprising particularly interesting
though is how they're going to spend
that money cyber security top of the
list for many of these companies uh
closely followed by marketing
technologies and artificial intelligence
interestingly they rank above buzzwords
like web 3 crypto currencies and the
metaverse
this cyber security chart shows how the
pace of change in cyber security alone
is going to change in a typical year 11
of companies might spend thirteen to
sixteen percent of their budget on cyber
security that is going to double this
year as more spending is planned on the
space
we're gonna be carrying out this survey
every quarter we'll keep you updated as
to what we find it's gonna provide some
fascinating insights into the direction
of travel in technology
[Music]